can you tell me this without getting
into your business too much have you
made more money as a personality than as
a rapper
12 15 times more money as a personality
okay I'll say this
four years it took me four to five years
to get a monthly check with music that I
can you know survive off of that ain't
going extra or anything like that I
passed that up my third week of doing my
streams I mean my third Mark for
Community yeah wow past three years up
because you were like getting advances
at I feel like you have an album at
every distribution [ __ ] I had bro I
feel like you were bouncing around
grabbing [ __ ] bags I mean I needed it
yeah no I know but I remember I forget
me and you were talking or and I was
like yo are you on Empire and you're
like I'm On Everything [ __ ] we got some
[ __ ] on Foundation we got bro Foundation
Empire
um
um shout out to fuzzy we did a deal with
priorities
we did everything under the sun you know
what I mean so it took you three months
to of doing your own [ __ ] not even the
no jumper [ __ ] not even no jumper Shoe
Right my second month in the community I
seen the check and I said what the [ __ ]
wow it was it was Game Changer it was
life-changing
now for people who do the the or want to
do the streaming thing right there's a
different app that you obviously are on
caffeine now child together but what for
you did you notice was the most before
caffeine came into the picture uh was it
YouTube or twitch that was more
well my goal was and you know shout out
to Ace boy pun
um pun bought me a white board and he
was like you know what because we start
seeing the no jumper [ __ ] was really
working and you know Adam gave me my
show uh once Adam gave me the show we
start seeing the numbers and everything
climbing everything started happening
and then
I tried twitch three times before it
worked so at first I just wanted to play
video games and just I was like I'm good
at video games I started playing
fortnite at my crib at my old apartment
and you know I just had my son right you
know I mean my son's probably like one
years old my son's running around I
don't got no nice background I'm doing a
twitch thing 12 people coming right so I
get discouraged I sell all the equipment
then we came up with a plan with a was
shout out to Seaside stretch shout out
the wheel we was like all right we gonna
turn this streaming [ __ ] to something
dope we wanna we wanna got a spot bought
a stripper pole we bought all type of
equipment and me and all miles Parish we
ended up teaming up because he was he
already was a partner on Twitch
um so we teamed up and we started doing
that every Monday we just call it the
Monday show and
I think the most we had was like 30
people watching us get discouraged again
sell the equipment was that after you
did no jumper yeah this is why the man
no jumper like I do remember the miles
Parish thing yeah so we we started that
but it's like it wasn't it wasn't moving
at the pace where I felt like it was
worth committing to every month and I
ended up um getting my new crib and I
was looking for a three bedroom and the
crib was actually four bedrooms and I
looked at the bottom and I said this is
a whole bedroom the other bedrooms on
the third floor it's all the way from
each other I'm like this is the perfect
setup I'm like I gotta get this spot and
then right there I was like this is
where we're gonna put all the stuff
right here it's away from the bedrooms
nobody got to hear me make noise or do
anything like that my kids and yeah man
we sat in that room we got it and once
again I just wanted to play video games
and um the first time that we streamed
and it's been it's been one year we just
hit our one year anniversary I remember
when we did the corner store brunch I
think you guys just started just started
yeah and we were playing video games and
I seen what 200 people in there I was
like wow all right we on we on to
something now and then it it just
adapted because all I wanted to do and
on my whiteboard all I wanted to do was
get uh what was it
500 subscribers just for the year yeah I
was like you know poem was like we gonna
start small we're gonna build this up
we're gonna do this and do that and it
went from playing video games because
they just started asking me questions
while I'm playing the video game and I'm
like hey
they're like hey what about this they
have to ask me questions and I just
start answering so then I'm like they
don't even want to see me play video
games so now they wanted me just to talk
and do topics and stuff and you know we
started implementing them freestyling we
just just showing the Personality yeah
just just shooting the [ __ ] and them
numbers just started just started
shooting up and then we didn't even want
to do YouTube I just said we twist twist
twist twitch shout out to our moderator
Clint Lowe quinlow was like I could turn
your stuff into clips from your streams
and then we were like okay whatever
he start you know making the clips we
started seeing like damn people are
really watching the Clips on YouTube and
then you know shout out to him he gave
us ownership of it and he you know
that's my moderator he works for us now
um he gave us ownership of the page of
the channel because he made the channel
he made the channel just on some like
just like on some on some like just you
know he was a a fan of watching you know
there's a lot of those there's a lot of
those like Joe Rogan and no jumper
channels too like that on YouTube he uh
he gave us ownership of it and then um
yeah bro we started we started making
some real chili and then that second
month the first month I was like okay
this is nice the second month I was like
whoa I was blown back I was like I never
made this much money
in one month ever in my life so T
Grizzly made 115 Grand in one month he
showed me on his phone what's your best
month
not getting into any numbers no get into
some numbers
I want to say overall this is what
everything combined content-wise I would
say close to like
50 60 in a month yes that's what
everything combined you feel me yeah
that's beautiful man yeah